foreign
[Music]
if you wanted to um you know go out
sometime you want to get a coffee now
yes now
I'll just hang on when I wake up well I
know I'm gonna be here her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy but I
think she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word she goes to them I bet she
hasn't even seen your text she does
travel a lot for work go to her I'm
going to London
[Music]
amazing 5 000 miles to surprise a girl
you've only met once especially if she's
the one who ghosted yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan oh right
[Music]
thank you
where am I oh God you you have the wrong
guy I'm a former wait wait
can you walk goals
who are you CIA
so confused they kept asking me about
the tax man they asked you about the tax
man didn't think I am attachment
George attacks man oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I spotted Rock
you're the one who flew to London
it was a romantic gesture
get three bumpy Hunter on the cockpit I
want her like
bigger than you and me
it never occur to you that he could be a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
can you trust me is that a joke
where am I
oh fresh meat for the grinder pay him no
heed he is cute but he is there's gotta
be a way out of here there's no escape
the only hope is the story really comes
whatever those things are oh
we will destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
this is fun
we
go
[Music]
what is that
we're facing the greatest evil the world
has ever known she's executing our
people this is unlike anything we've
ever seen
[Music]
what's trying to kill us this time
pretty much everything
the magic is on a whole other level
we're outmatched
how are we gonna defeat them
I know what to do I can ask corpses five
questions and then they go back to being
dead
maybe I'm not saying it
yuck wonderful were you killing battle
yes great one more question right yes no
no that wasn't for you did that count as
a question yes damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay why
did you say Okay at the end of that I
didn't
fantastic where's the shovel
this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins
challenging to single combat if you win
you'll have your food down
amen
pick up yourself
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
[Music]
yeah not really
yourself
stop Gary court order for asset seizures
so they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true no that's my
cousin Gary I swear to God he's my
cousin he's my second cousin there's
something seriously wrong with you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose him
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange we'll
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
I bet that means sex my husband the code
breaker
you've just been so worried about our
son he's going to Princeton in the fall
no I've heard of it you know we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house the
shortcut you're my hostage
she got down there something for me
why you tried kidnapping me you're 19.
grow up
this kid is Undateable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island Iced
Tea
[Music]
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
one thing about me um
I don't know what to do I just know my
mom would have wanted me to save the
house I feel like you're just nervous
aren't you loosen them up we can go
skinny dipping what about sharks been
here jellyfish not the season it's
really the lack of life partner you're
sitting here right now okay
of a romantic romantic he's actually
really sweet
the best part about getting older is not
having to care what people think I'm an
adult now I can make my own decisions
that's good you want to savor it saver
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here get away from her
[Music]
Maddie you can't outrun I can't lose my
license
what's up
the ocean is a Mysterious World humans
know more about the surface of Mars than
the floor of the ocean and the sea
creatures who lived there well even the
ones you have imagined you've imagined
them wrong take the mighty giant Kraken
bloodthirsty monster Sinker of ships
where are you even getting this Krakens
are majestic creatures and Noble
protectors I'm just Ruby Gilman normal
teenager for Generations Krakens have
protected the Seas keeping us safe from
the most power-hungry and dangerous
creature of all the mermaid yes the
mermaid but people love mermaids
um
they do people are stupid
Chelsea mermaids are selfish vain
narcissists I am gorgeous yes Queen the
worst of them all
are you okay I know your secret you're a
kraken hiding is a human you really
gotta go now and soon everyone will know
the truth
are you ready for your destiny I just
want to live my life
you have powers beyond your imagination
this is your moments Ruby
[Music]
I'm not gonna hide anymore
Grandmama I want you to teach me how to
use my Powers camouflage super speed
body armor let's see what you're capable
of
laser eyes yes they do pack a Wallops
you're just a dumb teenager
knock knock no matter what the challenge
a kraken will always and serve us all
it's time to go big
[Music]
you play the part for man
but you are a Lost Boy
or we could annihilate everything
oh you're totally serious
all right here's the situation that
wizard gave me superpowers and then
everybody got superpowers
no the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us but we come there in gifts
that's a hard pass that's a hard pass
but I've seen all of the Fast and the
Furious movies and it's all about the
family
okay
we end this now
yeah we do
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
let's try that again but with ninja
stars
hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
wait did you hear that what was that
well not that we can do you guys want to
grab pizza
what the heck are those things those are
like little Shreks to me
we've prepared our whole life for this
Hannah
oh my God
what happened is
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo well we prefer
the term ooze but yeah it's like more
like it's just it's rolls off the tongue
better yeah
it's nice right
[Music]
how long's the flat Daddy you start
taking a nap on the runway when you wake
up we'll be back home in Louisiana
[Music]
96 bravo bravo enter the pattern on left
downwind
[Music]
sacrificing your Easter Sunday just to
fly us home you're welcome to light up
front looks like the space shuttle got
Moon between the taxi
turn your headset you can listen to me
talk to air traffic control from the
trafficking site are you staring with
your feet yep
here we go
why may maintain one four thousand
aren't you supposed to repeat back what
he just
Joe
Miami Center anyone there say your till
number intention Doug what's going on
I've got an emergency up here my wife
and daughters are on this plane
I need to stop a plane crash you're the
only person I know can save them has he
flown to King Aaron never
we've got a very tight window how long
has it been in the air
we got a real good co-pilot up here
we're down
I've been looking for the emergency
procedures no doubt we're gonna need it
[Music]
from right toward the storms
I love you girl you can do it sometimes
you gotta trust me things you can't see
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
you broke the rules you went to the
above World a man was drowning I had to
save him this obsession with humans has
to stop
I just want to know more about them
[Music]
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
hahaha
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
someday
[Music]
you look you're a mermaid that doesn't
make us enemies
[Music]
down
ages
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
you blessed her with that ass with that
ass you don't mess around and get an STD
humping that ain't gonna be a Sanctified
transmission
oh my gosh I always wanted a sister and
here you are your cousins yes cousin
sisters it's the South it doesn't even
matter
so this is our church I am starting to
feel the spirit hey everyone this is my
cousin's sister Sam she's from L.A
staying with me now nice to meet you I'm
Melissa captain of the price team let's
take it from the top Break Every Chain
Break Every Chain this song needs to
life up in here Sam could help she
writes songs the chorus is the strongest
part of it we lose the rest and type the
Loose Ends it could be really special
lose the rest
every team has their life and our lane
is real church music how about you learn
an actual gospel song first
time's the only thing Atlanta has gone
for it okay about to go up in there
about to meet him it's about to be great
I would like to thank my cousin Jess for
being my ride or die in Atlanta when my
dad forced me to go out there and I
didn't want to go out there that's
family business we outside oh God
your voice is nice why don't you come
down to the studio
you should say that song at that church
thing
[Music]
I changed the music what it's gonna be
great we are terrified I don't really
have a relationship with God God use
fish donkeys even hoes to get his word
across what's going on I think she just
called me home
oh I like this twerking for the Lord we
do not think you're going straight to
hell as some people have said oh Church
Girl Gotta put him out there
[Applause]
so y'all really think God's gonna waste
a miracle on y'all this year huh so I
heard that clap back all the way over
here let's get our praise on
three songs hit people's heart a little
different hands on
[Applause]
[Music]
radical Pros
can I get an amen
[Music]
thank you
Mr Williams little on the frosty side
perhaps
not too much fun and laughter brother
like church
how does it up
it's more wonder I didn't notice what I
was becoming dad you're right
[Music]
we've only to be alive for one day
but I realized
I don't know how
[Music]
do you think we shouldn't alert the
Police about what will the police
together is a couple of hours left to
work a couple of hours late for work no
one ever thought
[Music]
this man until yesterday was living a
hell of an existence
thank you
am I so very much do not wish to do that
[Music]
I wanted the summer to be remembered
next Friday I'll be three years since
they told me that they didn't think I'd
make it more than three years that's it
then we're celebrating that
[Music]
they've not seen the worst of it last
Saturday
what are you studying in this
ridiculously happy book it's interesting
when something is burned it's particles
are released into the atmosphere to last
on forever
[Music]
display that we possibly can and will
burn the items that we collect like
Vikings and in doing so I'll live on
you're taking him from all of us
if I'm a normal person
makes
love you and the best part of my life
has been getting to know all four of you
what we're doing now means that I can
begin with him
[Music]
now fly my lovely little poles dude
mail for you
[Music]
[Applause]
the magical Zoo store announces the
nominations have started you are one of
the first two children to get a magical
animal
wow
you must swear to never speak about the
animals
hey Ginger I'm robot
I'm Henrietta
did I just hear a dog howling no it's
modern pedagogy
I want to learn everything about human
beings like what everything
there are rumors
that I unfortunately
we'll find the real Thief we're the best
master detective duo in the world
Sly as a fox
[Music]
suspicious very suspicious
[Applause]
you won't believe who I was spying on
[Music]
Rebecca give me your hands pull me over
they are truly your friends for life
[Music]
there is another special place
up in the Himalayas
it's called the Tiger's Nest I know
about that place
[Music]
come with me come out
to come get it
good tiger you took care of me I call
you mukti
they're asking where the mother is she's
gone mukti's alone like me
so why are you taking it to the Tiger's
nest
he'll do anything to get that cover
she'll need a mother though if she's
going to survive
[Music]
for almost 20 years I've been moving
these antennae around in vain to make
contact with outer space as soon as you
arrived the signal started coming
I believe that you
are a human
and
human antenna what is your status over
I got a dog
[Music]
what's your name my name is Obama oh
crap
oh crap where are we going now little
darling come on follow me oh no this is
not happening I think it's best if you
go to waltz flat Walt this is Obama
uh no my name's actually Brittany
Brittany
why don't you crafts with their
spaceship and a man came and took it and
now she can't get home oh my word that's
Robert is he a bad man no no he's not a
bad guy but his brother is we will
finally know the answer does life exist
in outer space and more importantly can
it be stuffed
we need to get to the spaceship little
antenna before he does we gotta hurry I
love that kind of enthusiasm let's go
please
here we go
let's see what to do about this
[Music]
I can see the whole world wonderful
I promise you we'll get your spaceship
tomorrow huh
would you like a cup sure thanks maybe
just half a cup
[Music]
[Applause]
moment
s
you can't just sit out here all alone
night after night you know how many jobs
there are in this town one
[Music]
stop
are you a soldier
Lauren my name is Carmen
[Music]
somebody
foreign
[Music]